E aí
[Música]
e hoje eu quero apresentar vocês um novo
olhar para a doença de alzheimer um
olhar mais terno um olhar mais carinhoso
um olhar sem pena só com amor e gratidão
Bom primeiramente eu gostaria de
apresentar para vocês com a experiência
de despertar o mesmo interesse que eu
tenho
os motivos para o quê Porque eu escolhi
este tema
primeiramente pela primeira pela
Primeira ideia do Tex ideias que merecem
ser discriminadas eu acredito que a
minha ideia merece ser disseminada pela
empatia que ela gera pelo fato de ajudar
pessoas que têm essa doença tão triste e
além disso pela complexidade da doença a
doença de alzheimer é uma doença
inteligente que sabe o que está fazendo
que sabe que destrói famílias e muitas
outras consequências
Olá primeiramente eu vou dar para vocês
uma introdução à doença de alzheimer uma
coisa que muitos não sabem é que é
Alzheimer não é o doença separada e sim
uma variante da demência
Além disso é uma doença
neurodegenerativa
ou seja é pros sensual vai vi orando Com
o tempo ela também funciona por atrofia
cerebral
que é como se a sua massa cerebral mais
fácil assim como a gente pode ver nessa
primeira imagem a e nesse nesse visual
mais três dele
e
ela também Ela atinge o hipocampo que é
esse lugar no centro do nosso cérebro
que é que é responsável pelas Memórias
de longo prazo e aprendizado de curto
prazo e é por isso que a usar Mas tem
como sua principal característica
a perda da memória
por último a doença de alzheimer
funciona por um gene ou seja um fator
genético por exemplo se um avô tem a
doença é provável que seu neto Tenha
também
a minha experiência com a doença de
alzheimer Bom dia eu fui convidada
quando eu tinha uns 8 anos para casa de
uma amiga no interior de São Paulo
elas tinha uma lá na casa dela eu vi uma
velhinha faxina corcunda
muito confusa eu fui alterando ao longo
dos dias não estava triste nem nada mãe
tinha um bom amor mas não sabia onde
estava eu não reconheci as pessoas que
quem estava então decidi perguntar para
minha amiga tá tudo bem com ela o que
aconteceu ela me falou que a vó dela que
a ser avó dela e ela tinha Doença de
Alzheimer
o Alzheimer como eu fui buscar é uma
doença que faz você esquecer também
conhecida como a doença do esquecimento
também fui descobrir que na minha
família tivemos um caso de Alzheimer o
caso de Maria do Carmo Lia que morreu
aos 90 anos
vindo direto do interior de Pernambuco
até Recife
e eu carrego um gênio E aí claro eu
poderia ficar me lamentando todos os
dias aí me avisa vai ser por nada se
você não vai esquecer certo ou eu podia
aproveitar cada dia como se fosse o
último
encontrar em todos os dias uma
oportunidade de reinicializar de
recomeçar e viver a minha vida ao máximo
com maior
ênfase que eu consiga
é como se manter positivo durante essa
jornada nessa jornada eu não quero dizer
apenas a jornada dos portadores de
Alzheimer ou de quem cuida mas também a
jornada até chegar lá sabendo que você
tem a Gêmea como você se mantém positivo
ou encontra felicidade nisso encontra
beleza bom eu acredito que é possível
encontrar a beleza em tudo que a gente
faz
inclusive nas coisas mais terríveis como
essa doença
E para isso você sempre tem que ver o
lado bom ou seja ver como a partir dessa
doença você vê que você precisa
aproveitar sua vida todos os dias
viver com maior
vida que você pode ter
o olhar de quem cuida depois de uma
pesquisa eu busquei uns trechos de
pessoas que cuidam de portador de doença
de alzheimer
tem que ter muita cautela procurar e não
se focar muito Alzheimer a dor do
esquecimento época
essa é uma frase que eu gostei bastante
porque muitas vezes esquecemos que um
portador de Alzheimer teve uma vida teve
ensinamento não foi não é apenas um
portador de Alzheimer e sim uma pessoa
que teve sua carreira teve sua família e
teve sua formação
e o Alzheimer não é doença da pessoa e
sim uma doença da família aprendendo a
cuidar de quem tem Alzheimer Drauzio
Varella essa eu achei muito legal porque
essa eu me identifico até hoje vejo as
consequências da doença de alzheimer na
minha família o medo de cortar o gênio o
medo de quando chegar no final
ter sido por nada
o bom humor faz parte tudo aquilo que
pode ter graça incorpore faça rir
permita-se rir junto Fernando aguzzoli
entrevista para a revista pro diet Essa
eu gostei bastante porque aí que a gente
encontrou otimismo a gente não pode
esquecer que essa pessoa também tem
emoções o portador de Alzheimer também
quer rir também quer ser feliz mesmo que
não sabe o que tá acontecendo
todo mundo quer ir
é bom como fechamento o que eu quero
dizer é que a gente tem que olhar para
essa doença como uma forma da gente como
incentivo a gente todos os dias
aproveitar mais e mais a nossa vida
viver para a vida seja
memorável que você não precisa esquecer
dela
e obrigada pela atenção espero que vocês
tenham gostado e
[Música]